faire caca les quatre fers en l'air avec
un drap sur moi j'ai des collègues qui
poussait pousser une sage femme qui est
à côté une perfusion de péridurale et
son mec sa part est drôle comme ça tout
simplement là quand même envie que ça
sorte un peu du tableau on envie
d'oublier ce détail
et quand on pose la question des fruits
bien sûr oui ah bah oui c'est quelque
chose quand d'autres dont on m'avait pas
parlé pas
[Musique]
je crois que la parole est assez pu
libérer peut-être parce qu'on a peur
qu'elle soit décourageantes et que la
vie on a besoin que les bébés naissent
et que la vie continue qu'on ait peur de
rien je crois que le raconter tout ce
qui nous arrive pendant l'accouchement
et pendant les trois premiers mois la
tête peur que ce soit je sais pas
affolant on n'ose pas parler
déjà parce qu'on a quand même au dessus
de nos têtes cet ace de peur d'être une
mauvaise mère
déjà si on confie nos peurs les plus
inquiet mais si tout d'un coup on n'aime
pas c'est notre enfance on a du mal à le
rencontrer au début quand il est né fera
tout et on a peur de s'inscrire dans
cette espèce de honte ce serait de ne
pas être une femme valable légitime
normal une bonne maman celle qui se
réjouit tout celle qui perd ses kilos
facilement toutes ces nanas l'acquis
instagram toute la journée pour leur
raconter pour nous raconter que leur vie
est un rêve
on a un peu du mal à se confronter à
sable qu'on a l'impression qu'on est un
peu seul avec d'autres petites misères
petites misères qui est vraiment qu'une
petite misère parce qu'encore une fois
toutes passées que en général c'est des
femmes très courageux qui s'en sortent
toujours et est très bien et puis
surtout il ya un truc c'est qu'on oublie
c'est à dire qu on oublie une fois que
le bébé est là on oublie plein de choses
on oublie même les contractions on
oublié comme l'a été la dernière semaine
on oublie et ce qui se passait dans une
petite culotte parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de tout ce qui s'y passe à la dernière
semaine on va pas se raconter
d'histoires parce qu'on est là pour
faire respecter et oublient un peu parce
que finalement avec les soldats c'est
pour ça que la mémoire est bien fait on
se souvient que des jolies choses
[Musique]
j'ai commencé à voir la tête cardiff ce
que j'ai raté ma fille dans son berceau
je me disais alors que mal occupe tout
le temps j'adore ma fille j'ai tout de
suite aimé était là dessus je ne veux
pas qu'il ya un doute mais c'est quand
même quelque chose d'avoir un enfant qui
sort de son corps enfin c'est quand même
pas c'est pas c'est pas d'une évidence
folle
[Musique]
je ne sais pas pourquoi on représente ça
comme ça peut-être parce que c'est
l'idée qu'on s'en fait que
téléspectateur serais très déçu de voir
des choses autrement mais non je crois
que c'est fini ce temps on a cru en
accrochant hurlant on insulte un autre
mais kara konaré toi je crois que c'est
comment êtes-vous si ça se passe au
contraire dans un plus plus tôt dans un
silence dans un poteau dans un silence
je dirais pas un silence de mort loin de
là ça c'est affreux de dire ça mais un
silence paquet qui sous-entend donc la
concentration le sérieux la respiration
ce qu'on vous apprend à respirer à
lisier poussé gynécologue en général est
calme sauf quand il arrive quelque chose
au bébé et consorts kia et encore et
reste plutôt calme parce que si l'info
la mer alors tout se passera très mal il
faut lâcher internet doctissimo les
forums tous à avoir été ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui n'ont que ça à
faire le derrière l'ordinateur pour les
vois bien donner des conseils et des
conseils et des conseils puis au pacot
oublier quand même que normalement
enceinte on va pas nous le répétons
devient un peu des animaux donc on a un
instinct très fort et l'instinct vaut
mille conseil notre instinct baume il
conseille donc je crois qu'il faut aussi
beaucoup si à son instinct qu'en général
il faut quand même se dire que on va
s'en sortir qui vont pas attendre de la
terre entière qu'elle donne une solution
qu'en général il suffit de se poser cinq
seront de boire un verre d'eau de dia ok
tout va bien je vais me débrouiller tout
ira très bien